oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues évidemment
monsieur Savary que les départements ont
besoin d'avoir des moyens et des
dotations à la hauteur des enjeux qui
sont face à eux et des fragilités mais
aussi des ambitions que nous avons pour
les plus éloignés de l'emploi pour
qu'effectivement demain ils puissent
accéder à l'autonomie à l'autonomie
professionnelle à une situation qu'ils
aspirent à avoir pour autant est-ce
qu'il faut cet objectif loi que vous
visez le lier à l'augmentation ou non de
4% d'un minima social
575 euros pour une personne seule je ne
sais plus quel collègue le rappeler tout
à l'heure moi je sais pas vivre avec ça
vous savez vivre avec ça moi je sais pas
pour autant ça ne les ça n'exonère
personne et aujourd'hui il ne me semble
pas que un seul département en France
n'est pas mis en place un dispositif qui
fasse en sorte d'accompagner chaque
bénéficiaire du RSA dans un parcours de
retour vers l'emploi sauf qu'il y a des
personnes quand il rentre dans ce
parcours qui sont en situation
d'illettrisme qui sont situations de
décalification complète et qu'avant de
pouvoir retourner directement à l'emploi
et bien il faut accéder à toute une
série de solutions de formation
peut-être d'insertion dans des
structures des régies de quartiers etc
oui et ben il faut les moyens mais ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que la
personne qui malheureusement pas en
situation d'accès à l'emploi directement
on l'a punisse on l'interdisant de
pouvoir nourrir ses enfants décemment
pour autant il faut être exigeant et je
suis d'accord sur le fait et je vais
vous dire dans le département du Nord et
croyez moi ça nous déchire le cœur sur
110000 bénéficiaires du RSA il y a 10
000 allocataires ont deux ans qui ont
quitté le RSA parce que ils avaient la
situation qui correspondait à une offre
d'emploi ils l'ont refusé plusieurs fois
d'affilée ils ont perdu le bénéfice du
RSA et croyez moi ça fait l'objet d'une
analyse sociale et professionnelle fine
malheureusement pour eux ils l'ont perdu
j'en suis bien désolé mais juste pour
vous dire que ceux qui sont bénéficiaire
du RSA aujourd'hui c'est parce que
véritablement ils sont engagés dans un
parcours ce ne sont pas des gens qui se
sont mis à l'abri d'une disposition qui
les protégé d'aller vers l'emploi ou de
faire un effort sachez bien que là il
s'agit juste de donner les moyens à
chacun de pouvoir subvenir à ses besoins
et là les plus précaires merci cher
collègue
[Musique]